[موسيقى]
اي وعاء معلومات
قسم الفرسه اللي هو العمود الفقري
للمكتبات فارس مرتبطه من جميع الاقسام
[موسيقى]
عبد الرحمن محمد
المكتبات والمعلومات من جامعه الامام محمد
بن سعود الاسلاميه
[موسيقى]
تقريبا انا 26 سنه
اطلق عندنا دائما اللي هو قسم الفهرسه
اللي هو العمود الفقري للمكتبات هو المنبع
يعني ما في فهرسه كان ما في كتب كمال
قبل هذا في طبع
الفهرسه مره مراحل طبعا قديمه خلال انشاء
المكتبه فيها مرحله كنا اول ما بدينا كنا
فارس يد الورقي بعدين تطور الامر الى
النظام الكتروني طبعا
[موسيقى]
مخطوطات سمع بصريه مواد مسموعه
معلومات
[موسيقى]
الان بيدخلونها في نظام جديد
الكتب تيجي طبعا
مزوده من قسم التنميه المجموعات بعد
الشراء من دون النشر فيسجلون لبيانات
الاوليه طبعا فيجي الفارس نكمل البيانات
كامله
من الصفحات من التصنيف من الفهرسه بحيث
انه من التبصره من اي شيء موجود في الكتاب
يكمل البيانات كامله ما تطلع مثلا
الا كامل البيانات وبعدين مكعب ترميز معين
بعدين يرحل المجموعه
تصنيف دي والعشري تصنيف المعمول بها في
المكتبات طبعا
تقسيم المعرفه اقسام ومقسمه طبعا عشري لين
النهايه
تراجم 922 طبعا والسنه
وهذا كتر مؤلف طبعا كل المؤلف اللغه رامز
الصالحات
ويحتاجين يؤثر عليها
طبعا كثير محتويات مقدمه الكتاب يعني
تقريبا الالوان كتاب ما يوحي في متن
الكتابه
[موسيقى]
يشوف تقريبا العناوين المشابهه
الخبره طبعا مثلا
يا صور مثلا خليه عامه سياسيه يتكلم في
العقيده ياكل الغلو طبعا
اللي عنده بحث او ماجستير طبعا وياخذ
السيدان من الرئيس
[موسيقى]
لازم يكون فيها تركيز
تركيز لازم يكون مثل نشيط احيانا عنده
مهارات تواصل يعني تواصل مع زملاء احيانا
لازم يكون عنده مهارات يعني المهارات حسب
الالي لازم تكون عند المفارس طبعا
والثقافه يكون عنده ثقافه عامه لان بعض
العلوم
[موسيقى]
الكلمات
بالعربي فيحاول يقربه
في همم في وقت تواصل الاجتماعي بحيث اني
اعرف الكلمه اذا ما عرف يرجع للمراجعه
والله احيانا مكتبي كان اول يوم فارس كان
اكثر مليون كتب مكتبي
فانا يعني القراءه حب الثاني
[موسيقى]
انا عندي مكتب البيت